A play.
Why why viewers very smart
and so over seventy years ago Ambareesh hall of home was Are you sure it never went to hospital asking about her
perform time with a nurse that sort of say. And therefore hospice in the front room.
And the nurse delivered you and that person it. Is all in the middle.
I have two or elder brothers and two younger brothers. Two sisters.
Some years ago camps are Unfortunately ours were seven in the family. He's.
Which is the way of anything walking the walk. So there's more of them to perish. Where are worth what I was doing.
I think I just lacked everything I love going out. Short of saying things. And point what I'm saying. Already.
Because I just love. Everything more a lark. Now. And you can remember where he's going to go for. One round. Stop.
Clark. From the room. Is three years. It's all here since he. He said You have to firmly. For all of them. He hears.
To vary from. Simply you were not really an issue. Neither weren't very many people there's eighty years ago or more.
Well my mother's sister my arms. Of I went to first from the thing all the ships went to prison.
And I settled there and my mother and father. And I had my eldest brother and sister Cross were born and mom.
With them. And my mother hastened to hate and with Bridgeman and their stars for four hours.
He's a person of my of I came back should make a match for a part of our family members. And. Hear from Americans.
I think. And I have long by having been the first. Not very long. Years years until I saw this is not from a.
To the family or someone there is no God This is just which. My brothers. But are my new star.
And this is have all happened the most were the. Oh you work for a couple of years in the very. In a new camp three.
He had trouble. Getting your all and. He didn't. That. Mother dear come. Father had.
To go back but then he washing bone and make sure he carried back. Machine he went to England as a young boy.
Well being of a all day. They all left or went or when they were sixteen or eighteen. He met my mother.
In the African Americans. Thank you. That's how it all began. You know they were shining in their pocket of the. Lord.
Which. You very much. So. Well I don't think I thought of that march. I don't think. So religion. Entered such degree.
What I knew I would. Anyway. Is there an official big community. So I think. You know. That fell into place.
I think I'm just for dramatic and life which say to you. And of course we're all born here.
The rest of us who want to go on and doing a lot of. Far from here. That don't seem very new problem.
We or us haven't half hours. Well. Or as. Didn't seem to me or anything.
Because nothing about as dangerous much easier anyway. We thank you thank you. When. You know something about. Race.
So. Yes. How can the Indigo. Three. Which they didn't have will certainly be. When I think I'll join the fix cause.
You know our so. I was always interested in. The people. I know are. Now I didn't like.
I just like going to our friends. Well I just love being there. So if I didn't have to learn. Them.
It took a very odd sort of barrier of there with all our What in particular. But I do it because of the earth. But.
Now I just think. I think I like sharing all of that and not remember what I did with this there are.
Felix which was we Rick Perry. That was like. That was a little bit later. But. So. Yes I didas America fair here.
And again by a bit of very smart. Or have we know we're still there where we were. Knew that they lived up on the Hill.
They were here for out those farmers younger you know. What not that they were for.
You know they're about five friends of the younger one of them. But we aren't seeing it for serious.
And we've barely Rob. I couldn't have been more them over there because I was there. And it was my son. So I am.
A guy I work actively aren't proud of my for my uncle.
And the other while of how much he had fun with to have fun but we didn't.
There was anything wrong here on the top of his very desire to do
or what his sources are saying you kept secrets of it until it was the largest thought it was a natural thing to do you.
I didn't know I was meant to sort this stuff coming out of you. And so isn't this exciting.
You're very aware that our years. Oh years. I will remove the film that we have on our live shots of this one.
And because you do it for us exciting and for some of your life you know it was so fun. The whole.
The sky the journey of the special. Video. Story. Sexual experience the way. You.
Come out of sex or so will be relevant but it can work with you know. All the way.
Here But that's not saying much to us very. Well. When I was cruel our powers.
About oral so this was a little bit about science about the science. It was all happening from a you know.
I just talked to a whole group want to go there where I live give them some one description of my mother's work for.
Things like that.
I mean I would give them a three way Apple I could have them but something about a very large very very friendly
and sort of. You and I were over there. We have them now. And we're driving them and out of the Civil War to get them.
I just want some to be our friends so. I didn't walk about I want them very much French and I like them. And. I prefer.
Really really go for it. How Yes I just saw facts that you and I did locally and where you're the person.
I visit them or my you and are. We were. And there are so and one was how. The repairs.
But that didn't end the current affair that didn't worry me a whole lot of a lot of.
What I hear now you're dying to really have prayer is your life you get to school with friends and.
They never ever mind. Providing Raman live. I have very few theories. From my friend. Chris.
And in fact i didn't matter where they were if I lack the most of the matter WHAT they were.
I didn't know what religion people were if you're really here. Yes or they were fearful of.
The power of the says I'm real you know in the real world.
Yes when I do an occasion very successful they are very successful.
A family and I knew of his wife long before America.
Long before him and I have to say here but when you sit there with I actually like you lots of good. We hear you. Eric.
Very well die because of this you say you. And I were close right. You say there are five.
Young boys or something close and I think because our houses that are closer. Where the one they've been.
And the other one the relative. STRANGER. If I said the wrong way. Or you do. Feel guilty for a year or two or three.
I do or mars of am. Yes. I think I might have many more to us. I thought if a man will give.
Out surfing here for telling. Him for free. Have I made it through the first. But I face was my brother. Who may.
I have five brother and yes. The man next to me. And. I used to sort of say where you carry the emotion.
Oh I'm going round to see this man mind. I don't know how to go through working for each other with Marcos you know.
Why you do and they said he shares a book some things I expect him to stick.
Remember very well because we go away and he'd take us in oneness of time and.
We'd never never discuss from my brother about first what he did.
But I hate the way he would care for a child but that he was sharing a full of wonderful full.
And it was fun as I was saying if we never discuss. A half. When we were. Here we are going to.
It was a very exciting it was fairy fairy exciting to have this. So you have you have come back from.
Them with a wonderful story. Well yeah Psylocke very well to go. But the environment that's out of this is.
For the for my wife for all about the whole issue
or from the first three that I thought House can't apply I have a copy of the globe out and I think we'll go there.
What do you think there's anything wrong with Prince Philip. I just think it just happened.
I think naturally but how did you start your career. Your way or look I think it happens so.
If I didn't watch that happen. I've gone out of the room.
It was pretty awful made through one of the few of them Hey that you've gone through it.
Yes but then he stopped to talk to me
but I didn't say for stop by the prophet more the longer a girl with nothing on for a year off an arm for eighteen
months perhaps. You know. Three. Oh yes our years who didn't let me go.
Now I was mistreated I lived with no one not even one.
Because he didn't appear from a box that he was very current but he didn't the feel. But I.E.
The fear of them what he was doing. We lived through your mind expanding out my understanding of.
Having both one after that I have a very quick prayer for the other boys and so if you want to hear. And I think.
If my driver anything over trash.
I think he was scared he would have more drama about the weather than I was ties that you know that i hold of me
and that these things. The boy is the future. Do you really. I just thought he'd lark to found out that.
I was really a troll.
If I defied the law because of what love was
but to push back there for our looking back Mary report of what he was doing if he was very careful with the forty
eight years he was about here. There were three. They've been there. Who Hello.
All are no but there to my sisters and my my child of a well you know if I were of sixty
or fifty are that they were out in May of my head. Right here and very frightened by if they were gentle and.
And I have the comfort there are you want to say my brother to your back shortly.
Yes
when I go on Long Beach in the very way he will show you the full philosophic capsule avers day at the Imperial Palace.
I'm here and I am merrier for the rakyat from the Fed put it to matter of fact.
Go here also gentleman lies about a group you found.
I don't know what he really is no no no nothing like that
and I bet that the men from here it is just one of those things that happen.
And I didn't think it was significant wrong doing.
If you from your review you and I because I thought this was something of the wrong person from longs for me.
This is my little thing. Because of course I did not know that he was doing it for my brother. I only saw this.
But I thought for this day you have to leave the last of me doing out there you know.
Best he said just above the full time but I didn't.
I never worried about I was very selfish for a while over here so they're here start to figure this belongs to my young
birds or something out of my secret with some of this. If you figure for the money so long as you move a little.
In our work because. Well either way you never discuss Postal thing.
You go with my mouth and from where I work you do a chorus of
or something to them for something wrong to me I felt my my not sacred. But I do know you'll now go for it.
Now girl because I enjoyed it. Except a little in the mid nineties they see it as many. You see people here anyway.
Rather wild life out there guilty I would love them back there. For more don't you know it but you know.
Five of them are filthy. Because I enjoyed it. How did you actually get sixty five. So there was no line.
Facts are my ideas come from there ever ever were never discussed. Never discussed and from a big family.
Of them I said think of this so often for men to care for all the free world.
So school school who it was a whole crew for.
I think it all happened naturally when you put your car wash you back for one hour now.
I thought I was special about then I was a marketable forth
and we never used to work cooperatively with us from fear of the word I meant that you were never swore you know.
What do you think about just having a best president this time having sex.
That you would want to go to all year just to do work or you wouldn't say getting off because getting our lives.
Much later. Much like. A fracture and a marriage just so you know all of the.
Very little kids talk about my I have a nice season with a you. Right. But the road. Now or Never.
You know like it will. Find and the arc here where I come from.
I wasn't terribly of that sort of thing I want to be for us.
Are selfish and I just went about my business and the critics were. Right. It was kind of.
The one you mention the rule if you get to where I just sort of a mob this is big three. And.
Just growing with all these figures are it proceeded from a for a while before so much real that it was all very nice
going to magically a really good big deal to make this beautiful faces. Yes I would take some.
If you were waiting for your call. But what there were. Yes I still think if after this. You write the three.
In the middle of somebody's back yards away. The middle of the. Cohesiveness of. The room you will.
I suppose if it is a theory that you will go in your one way or the. Or I think. The mouth of. All of our years will.
Home already knowing. Another something quite have the comfort of my own little. Say that for my own. Almost sacred.
For my fish and I feel so far from the river.
Right there with you from the same way of life that will live there but what you're doing here.
Dr Yes And you know now back to the ever since the turn off of Earth where I was you and I
when I was where I will you know have a river of your own where it's a religious ceremony but I'm out of there.
If you become a very slack in the other religion when you quit while some Whether you're a man or a so take one
when you were with you at the center call you back. You're away for several weeks with.
One of my commentary for your part of the book.
I don't really know you aren't I was in there and you've been reading all these and I mean you were a lot worse at the.
What they call the very Central Synagogue of theory from the start but from a girl. One of whom we.
You know when I when I was called there many years ago. It was in Grafton Street.
Although many years ago I was in rough and very loudly filled with beautiful girls live there
and we all where with only. It's a morning so I went in the.
You have the big car and I will say the power that we had over him on the bill could get them or the house.
You know the room where they were doing. You were involved I am going to go around the house with them.
Because the house where we were often taken the place for all you know living for wherever the road.
It was and I was in Wellington three where it came to go there. And wait if I was lucky us. Lucky.
Call it very very big back right. Back on the are all.
When we have a mark a recent article came out for the numbers this bright. Or market for to me of him. And.
Where you were very particular my way home. Went aloft and. Him. And I are hungry.
But very few of my young friends share you. Of course my. Benefit from it were ours will work for.
I think neither work. They are all. By now. The boys so. I have to run.
Where they were they were all really is was my mother and father are friendly with that much help us.
And there are five of the family or certainly yes I went there.
Oh and the head of this family back home there for a month.
So it is for you in our cars how to talk and I got more kept things. I am going to hand out like a boy in the am.
And cafe and I will say I am. Our car.
It was marked our ticket so you might have to give us free or verse
but for those who are in the street where you thank him up and.
Thanks very much for buying thank you for bringing them up for you.
Well if you have that was what do you know you sit down.
Did you sit down in the room but they're working sort of as you are now or you will format away.
I think we have fish and chips. Were the power of arguing about it over. Marvin to show our love for you.
Or Grow Your Own Fool. We were very very good that you bring your own. If you look into the pool of years very much.
It was for aka. To go because it was with all the work for you. No no no wait. Help me have. So if you paid.
For did not. Was there was no after that was a normal thing to through the roof. Oh very much. So say so.
Where Oh I think I'm going to I just took a matter of course. Because you see question most certainly of anything. Old.
It's a question of the legs of the fallen by working fall from the bush. Far away all of that didn't make me.
Thank you very much for you know that if you found the wrong. Rafiq hour or half a world very happy family.
Amber Frey free to go there. My mother was one of my far. One. Or so good for us.
I don't think looking back like our homes were all very well I doubt my or my mum I was very gentle way.
And my father was a bit of a false if he was going to talk really about. You first his house from his house.
You from the mouth. How much money was not coming out of the rooms I think all. One. But everybody about my mouth.
Apart from everybody. For the rest of us NASCAR. If you're very cool cool cool what you think of it.
I think that was just a matter of course very regular you know getting on with their lives and.
Crock of shit over here. I was mad about I went right. I was very shitty for work and I have a killer set.
I want to go over and over and over but I was never man about.
If you haven't got it all and I think we did it because you went to primary school.
And then from Prime Minister with six or so. Then you work out your wish. For you to go. With you very very little.
And I was there. And I was I'm so you are. I'm not sure when you're.
OK at school even though you have a tree a longer one can reverse to go do it you know I hate this very well you are
just hated still getting large here or there and I didn't. My friends of anybody.
I didn't think there were others out there were very high just so I went to school because I had to go to school.
If I could get I'm sure it will all work. And I know we didn't know where you or you go.
So you know that we feel lonely.
But only after we didn't have the right group those who really care most about you will have your OK because you have
to do. Thank you. I mean are you from are swimming pretty far from a great source of workmen a big deal by doing good.
Do you really think recently. This is really a gray.
Well that's right and wrong when I was in the Army and I never got out of the well I never got out.
Good luck to have a good clue to get back in the car getting ready to do one of the around those two it was working
fine in the field with a bunch of practical. It's nice. Thank you for all. If you do if you like.
We say the focus was outside the school which is. Great. If you go so high I think just being at home.
Crowds of sisters. Going out. For a good question because we've got a lot of that.
What it takes for picnics he'd take us. Dry you know and I first have to we're going to go through Florida.
Case from our place.
We've got a few Wicked Witch Fire way
and I remember it very back is a boarding house little coffee one time people were going off here.
They were laughing and I think a courthouse on the veranda with a good will carry you through it. Yes.
And away some question. Should we bring. Here special saying you know it's all about. It's very difficult.
You get here but you are my father where we are preparing
and you said yes because my father was very friendly with Simon with you. Herrick. Yeah. Right right. Yeah.
Even years now. We just go up there for the day and have you learned very very fair play.
Of those so please grow your writing. So there's your view of your theory.
Far after all that you are going to if you're a good little kid will you feel of power. Yes or that we will every day.
I wonder if you really know what. Well we all have different frames usually having it all the time.
And actually in the process. This will make up for my family when we can go elsewhere.
After all without saying your crush is a problem. Where my sis is a year so absolutely right. What it is but yeah.
Here's. The rules we're very you know how. We have a way with our. Where are they all are over ninety dollars a year.
You are doing. Yes I wish the Domino Theory was Are you OK. Have.
Well we have now are going to hear much about right here. And. A fair fight. We just have to really get along.
In the locus of the room to go. Isn't her school. For you. When it first. This is very much as far as the go.
Oh yes because friends. Who normally sit and laugh with me or you know certainly do it for a short.
Call went by and then half way at the moment.
You walk in the road will go I feel like well before that we had we been in Bellevue.
You know their feelings for you and there was a smaller house but the first sunk A levels
and we rolled out for years before it was just a river. And that was for our mouse and luckily our. I'm out of the car.
And so have the truckers house with the road and.
People there but when you're young you don't care where you are you're just over there you go you go along
and you're thinking this where I'm going to do what I did not do it. You just fifteen. If you're a long year.
I dare say. When are you at your school. You were you were. Before I was outta here and you know all.
And I had friends who want to go. Well that one of those things happened. You know. There was a clue to grow.
You know how was the start for about after hours about. The hours of. Six thirty.
Now are there certain to say we were just don't wake up our. Get fresh. Yes. If you think about it.
Are now arguing for money they have to have thought it was crap and that. If you lack something.
There's nothing wrong with that to say if you die or clock in sync or there's something wrong. Having fun.
But I liked it and he was very nice. I remember. One other theory that he was a well.
And I have been just see here you were in the fashion business for good with scalar problem.
Do you think I have do you very practical or or I have to go down to them
and get some from you all for one know who the better jobs are here
or there were where I don't have to have a system most days in market place. Or a part time work.
I have it nice or so for you there.
Buy me a box and say well I'm here to have a guy there are some very nice to have to share you with us.
Do you ever track to people with those you know they're all going to hook it all and have about a ten.
There were in your group. Yes but I didn't know I just moved so obvious I didn't think there is a bigger car. You know.
And yes they are very busy. But that if I didn't look at it every day I was there. And I watch out for them.
Are you the woman that if you have dinner with your mother go on. So we're very very not horses so there is no sound.
And you will never buy them. All and it was a very. Well I'm going to do.
If you don't say what I wish I knew immediately. So it was sixty sixty. I didn't want it I screw with my choice.
You know my account of what I mean to the year from probably how. All of a sort of you would you buy me things.
And things are going to pay for my house. Now so we work really really really really you have to have a profession.
If you will but if you go. If you. Where all are very severe. But if you go you know where you are all.
Are working in just a few of their fashion apparently to pick up a whole thing of the sort of our beautiful son we were.
I think I learnt the horrors. But I think it was really easy it was starting out fairly to. I saw her. Yes.
Yes yes I did locker room. We wound up working with our long long hours of hours. There are a long road how jocose we.
And I always have to go away. Hot round messages and say hello.
Do other things and help around the room to the other you will. It's amazing. If it's a new one when you can watch.
Part of the march with. The full mark. And if you like it if you lack of sync seem to get that far and.
One of them ever remember. Some particular stood for because you are a good. Girl.
Here you are the good girl the girl the more you know we do it because you know you.
Certainly we're going to we're going. Now I have to buy some because we already have.
Captain did that I never go there. I might have a. Walk through or in queue to do it.
With some growth what was previously. I think reasonably Yes I didn't really want to look like.
What I think the commercial value in. The rule of the rule. Whatever short of a. Time for the rose.
Listener and you heard it here so far. Of working with your love the most universal approach. I have are the house.
About the house. That you're probably going to favorite place I go to work early. The thing.
The Windows Phone because I feel this is all yet. Complete with. Well. OK. But for long. So if you are in the home.
And know that ours is trying to have health care for whatever care cringe. You have to know.
Somebody really never show which was good and I you just social welfare for the service are far
and if I met some of the guys that Bush could benefit me I'd give it back.
I would just go to do you have one who is really more agree with you here.
But if we didn't care then we where we took our welfare all out to school now.
On the ground for free when your throat was over and. In our pocket I have it right here. So you know we have a right.
We may talk about the pay roll. We have in fact earlier you are now in my mouth where you were never on. That list.
You were going over there and I was feeling lonely. When it took me a pitiful four hours to get you to look out for me.
All right. I will be with you all. I have to do our network of long time. Well. When I asked for a psycho. At the time.
Good I knew I had it good will surely say who it was I you there when I should hear myself.
Have a member of the rivers with regular flu. Not really. You have a much bigger the use of power. You know.
In fact about that. I'm upset. And I have a car. In the strike three you like the car.
So if you thought you were talking about this or that it's like oh you know you should run for it
and he would do us your. Yes I don't know if you. So I was very friendly with John Williams. For you.
If you're going to do it if you can. It depends a good book on where you must carry and how much more you.
Room for years and he I had a lovely house. Have a market where the hell's happened.
And we have this out there and I have a tennis court. So are ours about something like this and I was right.
And I are right about. That. He was shaking. And it was. And she goes home.
You know me I'm sure you'll check your withdrawal. He was a bit of about how his father was the problem here and I.
William said have a. OK.
Home and there are some car hours and beyond that in the off duty all the property are off he went right.
On the problem. But he had checked just for me. And he was acting up. I think that the government is a bit younger.
You know if we have a correction or things like.
Our large him because the English have a look and he was interesting
and he didn't care about anything much that we believed or feel normal working. We love the look the ladder.
The film star our room looked a bit far. And Robert if you are in one of the out those.
Or if for example they were looking for a way to go over or go on until.
Somebody must have known something were you really going to show you what all of their hours.
And they did work which certainly.
Thank you for a little yes you have a hard on for it and he's living somewhere for a mushroom.
In some his house OK here. I'm going for the way back to see. Mark thank you. But we have growth and he has lots of.
He's alright. A strike would have a few days but that didn't matter. For all mixed in together.
And it was as if saying there was sort of the last minute hemorrhage. There are going to go right down here with us.
Property rights but the value of all records.
Will work for you to have powers of having a great thing to have a car if I call the world. I'm having a cocktail.
If you don't tell you having a power to have your car. Chapeau week. I want.
That all over years and I've come to me because of France. Back.
Out and we have marched me she actually was short for a few. And three of us about her peers all serious.
Filled with the feeling or really. Yes we are from Miami of the US and. The people in my group.
How they haven't come back to where where where were you. Because there are so far they're preparing their courses for.
If you. Go out by a guy. I think if we were to go along for the surface or some of them.
Go you would go on the night of nine hundred sixty.
I'm seventy three seventy one
and then you are you still a pretty Was there anyone would go to the bar as they return to Earth where you weigh
whether there's still a little bit of color or if they have a bit like our. There were a few years.
You had over a few place. Madam if you were of course I do or where you take a left hand. And we both.
Here are the we're going to herald. And he's about to I thought your fashion I saw pictures.
Out of Here on our way to measure here and also here at night it was very smart.
To go to add a whole bag of docking really about this. And why. And also. Here is a Mexico.
Home with a hole in the boat going to be a mess and I thought OK there we go.
And of course I know right where I was sure if it was a shock to you if you aren't changing a bit here.
OK I didn't mark Shalamar Shalamar pick up a little bit of your work which is really good from here.
You will if you will feel the king of all.
It push us of terrorism but I advise you just call those good continental What was the most current theory of.
Africa Schmidt civil war there is a good. Look where yeah.
You laid anything to you know and especially if you have a brick.
I think we wish you could very well hear what the Bush and she was good. You guys might want to keep our supply.
But remember I have found. Dar working her way. And having her out there for care of the care for.
What they call the madam here Mark I know who you are you are a serious guy
and you way home we began the interview we did speak to her. Yes you can be allowed. I should do.
I think Katie that if you. And she remembered she would we ever see. She go call.
We will explore a few and she told us what story if you recall.
She would be recorded as she said she saw the family as luck was a cheer up.
Oh sure fashion I think because she worked you say about it are very strong you know you very sharp.
I mean even they all of you cheat
and have to be in the right he will wear on the right if you're very very early on he is very much people she is sick
of guys. So she acts like a fool. She said from now it's all I ever sent me a year out an hour everyone.
Everybody Froude and there are five and I was that night he didn't go after much away from the ground
and I was thirty something years let's go around the time
when I was wherever Friday that's why it took me a long time for my family to get curious about washing coming home
from their perceived shadow not so much
but she said she had a risk here she did this in the early days will always be the right solution.
The place twenty two and the Royal are looking I was days I was curious and she wasn't very big you know
and she was so. I guess. She's much the race from our toilets all the time that sprout years of.
All of the years those years and she can remember Judge Joe. The beach one. Well. Oh yes you do next go.
Yes for the Arab world. I try to watch out for you. Anyhow to be on call there on a moment. Madam.
And you're so you know what the Earth will look like with a book a really top notch just care as you were.
With Kerry and from a strange place. I think. I didn't really have much I do live every year.
Image not our image using the word of a.
Why she had to have a man I think applied to finally hear this Everett she was trash ninety three. And one quarter.
Where you could get everything you want. So if you do it with Martha or you can matter you can carry on.
You weren't sure if you know what you do or you are just like we were Paris and it's interesting she said.
Because she was scarier so.
I'm not a guy that she doesn't know and I just feel that I have her out but I have no Why yes I do
and the a very human centipede actually off the first she was very juicy very Geo saved I am mad for all the game.
Actually if you back that little.
Can you shall be like me would get a summary of greenery she might look like a way to defeat lower exactly body just
exactly the act. I think she probably for you. Over go there for the good of this world.
Wherever they arrive very life for myself. Anyway even if you went to rather for dinner.
You have the app for symbiosis. Close by six o'clock.
So the use of rest for your own and then mandate then you go on to some fish. We have booking for our house.
Which covered with the reform bill. So far. It's true vs. First off of last year it was that sort of shite.
You know it would be on all small for all but you went from long. Twenty three. If you fear.
For the group or possible to get this from lots of. So there. Which I'm fine. Thank you. We're here. Here's our.
She's very old very human coaching ticket. She's very good. And a few forward for her head scarf.
Yes I'll have my first fashion by you know of course every which she was personality is really interesting which a
great deal goes through our years of the age of five years and she has most of my.
Joe Joe years crew were she had a big lunch try to get them. For her. But before you know. For three.
People now I don't get it. Just like a group of friends for the way. We really feel for a line you for war. You know.
With the river we met in the park here right. It was where are you really were. Are you.
When we were all where you want to go for the well for you
when we started you know for you know if you were Mark room or if you say of. The other three. Your brother the world.
He gave you and I was very fond of fall. And I had a marvelous suit.
Funny enough at the tail of my person before I let you and from the first Feel free to think that way.
Yeah I'm a large guy who was dark news for our studio. I was the first for our very far friendly with already..
To have a court. Come From. If you can. But any have for so often or she said or done with it was a way L.
After So like you or you are the better to not have some way.